gráfica es igual a x cuadrada menos x
menos 6 trazando el 2 puntos así que lo
que voy a hacer dado que me piden que
atrás de los puntos es una tabla con
distintos valores de xy con distintos
valores de james que voy a obtener al
sustituir la x en esta ecuación x la voy
a hacer variar desde menos 3 hasta 3
esta es como la forma de secundaria de
dibujar una función entonces vamos a ver
qué me queda si pongo menos 3 me queda
menos 3 al cuadrado es 9 menos por menos
me da más entonces es más 3 y después
esto que quitar de menos 69 + 3 12 menos
ahora vamos a ver con menos 2 qué pasa
con menos dos menos 2 elevado al
cuadrado pues menos 2 elevado al
cuadrado 4 menos por menos me da más +2
y después de esto que quitarle 6 más 2
menos 6 y bueno 4 12 66 es cero esto es
igual a cero vamos a ver qué pasa con
menos uno menos uno al cuadrado esto es
uno menos por menos me da más entonces
es más
y después a esto hay que quitarle menos
66 26 es lo mismo que menos 4 ahora
vamos a ver qué pasa con 0 0 al cuadrado
0 - 0 pues es 0 menos 6 me queda menos 6
esto es tan sencillo vamos a ver qué
pasa ahora con el 11 menos 1 pues uno
menos 10 menos 6 es menos 61 menos 10
menos 6 menos 6 y ahora vamos a ver qué
pasa con el siguiente número es decir
con dos puntos que va a pasar 2 al
cuadrado es 4 entonces hemos vivido 4 -
2 - 64 menos dos menos seis y esto es lo
mismo que cuatro menos dos que es dos
menos seis me da menos cuatro y por
último vamos a ver qué pasa con el 33 al
cuadrado es 9 menos tres menos 69 -3
menos 6 y esto me da 0 muy bien una vez
que ya tengo los respectivos valores de
x los respectivos valores de iu pues
vamos a ponerlos en esta gráfica que
tengo que la derecha estas medidas x s
y vamos a ver el primer punto es el
menos 36 camino 3 s la izquierda y 6
hacia arriba y entonces este es mi
primer punto este es el punto que
equivale a cuando x vale 3 y lleva de
6000 segundo punto es cuando x vale
menos 2 y ya vale 0 estamos en este
punto y en este valor de aquí cuando x
vale menos uno que vale menos 4 - 1 - 4
estamos por aquí entonces ya tenemos
otro valor de esta gráfica que vamos a
obtener cuando x vale 0 lleva de menos 6
así que vamos a bajar hasta -6 y ponemos
un puntito cuando x vale 1 también que
vale menos 6 así que vamos a bajar hasta
menos seis y ponemos otro puntito cuando
x vale 1 después en 2 x vale menos 4 ya
subimos otro poquito en 2 vamos a subir
a menos 4 y por último en 3 vale cero
cuando x vale 3 que vale cero es decir
que nos subimos y bajamos y ahora viene
la parte más difícil de todo esto que es
graficar esta función a ver si me sale
no no no esto está horrible perdón
perdón
vamos a intentar graficar y unir los
puntos lo mejor que se pueda piensa
vamos vamos por acá más o menos por acá
ya acabo hasta acá no me salió tan mal
pero déjenme intentar hacerlo una última
vez voy bajando voy bajando voy bajando
voy subiendo voy subiendo voy subiendo
perfecto ya me quedo mucho mejor y bueno
ya tengo la gráfica de esta función que
por cierto todas las ecuaciones
cuadráticas se ven igual se desconoce
con el nombre de parábola esta de aquí
es una parábola y en el futuro vamos a
ver otra forma de graficar funciones
porque esta forma de graficar funciones
no es la mejor ni la más óptima pero
bueno aún así obtuvimos la gráfica de
esta función que es una parábola
utilizando valores de x con sus
respectivos valores de g